commandant james reece de l'unité alfa
pouvez vous faire le compte rendu de la
mission
l'attak prônait l'unité alfa pour cible
et je ne mettrai plus confus sur le
calendrier mais il savait conviendrait
[Musique]
il mode est un sentiment paranoïaque des
troubles de la mémoire ont été piégés
[Musique]
on dit toujours que c'est mon
imagination
en particulier quand david affront
goliath et russe ce qui dans l'histoire
david et goliath j'en suis pas encore
certaine
l'enquêté toujours en cours concernant
les éventuelles défaillances qui ont
provoqué la mort de plusieurs des
missiles essentielle après l'échec d'une
opération qui avait coûté la vie à douze
de nos délicieuses
commandant james reece de l'unité alfa
pouvez vous faire le compte rendu de la
mission il savait conviendrait d'après
le fichier audio vous avez coupé la com
au bout de quatre kilomètres à
l'intérieur pourquoi
c'est pas ce qui s'est passé
tu va bien ça va
des maux de tête un sentiment
paranoïaque et des troubles de la
mémoire
on
va s'en sortir tu verras
tu veux me raconter ce qui s'est passé
on nous a donné une fausse info sur cani
on a été piégé
si vraiment j'ai raison je sais qu'il
faut réagir je veux des dons c'est un
lien avec vous et vos hommes je le
trouverai
les réponses ou du sang
du sang
oui james reece c'est vrai que ma
trottinette un avis il est poursuivi par
pas mal d'emplois auraient donc pour
l'instant mais là en veilleuse dont
douze de mes hommes rentrent au pays
dans un cercueil
c'est personnel
vous avez préféré jouer à la guerre
maintenant vous êtes sur le champ de
bataille
le mal est partout dans ce monde un
point que tu n'imagine même pas
gibbs
kita maison avec l'uci tout de suite
je vous le répèterai pas
ne soyez jamais son analyste